gta 5 for playstation 5 and xbox series
x and s has all new details so let's
talk about them
let's start with the graphics rockstar
said gta 5 and gta online will bring
high-end pc visuals to console with
multiple graphics modes and support for
frame rates up to 60 frames per second
players can also expect improved texture
quality options ray tracing and hdr
options fidelity mode is the highest
visual quality option reaching up to
native 4k or upscaled 4k on series s
with ray tracing in this mode the frame
rate is capped at 30. for performance
mode players will get 60fps gameplay
with upscaled 4k graphics on ps5 and
xbox series x with the series s edition
offering 1080p visuals there is also a
hybrid mode called performance rt this
is a middle ground between fidelity and
performance and it includes upscaled 4k
resolution with ray tracing at 60fps in
terms of other improvements gta 5 and
gta online for playstation 5 and xbox
series x and s has better load times
there is also increased npc population
and traffic variety according to
rockstar players can expect more
vegetation density and improve lighting
quality for shadows and water
reflections these new versions also have
improved anti-aliasing and motion blur
as well as highly detailed new
explosions fire and much more in
addition to these new graphical and
technical improvements gta online is
getting new content in the form of
additional vehicles from how special
works rockstar also reminded fans that
gta online will be offered as a
standalone download on march 15th
alongside the launch of gta 5 on the new
platforms playstation 5 users can get
gta online standalone edition free for
the first three months and there was no
mention of needing to have playstation
plus to take advantage of this offer
rockstar didn't announce any pricing
details for the game but pre-orders and
pre-loading starts on march 8th so we
should know very soon for those just
getting started in gta online or who's
just looking to begin anew rockstar
developed a new feature called career
builder that lets players create a new
character and gives them a four million
dollar in-game payment to spend on
things like business properties vehicles
and weapons gta online is also getting a
range of quality of life improvements
including a new tutorial and an update
to the main menu that lets you get
directly into modes like heist free mode
races weekly featured content and
adversary modes when it comes to
character transfers players can transfer
their progress from gta 5 story mode and
gta online from playstation 4 or xbox
one to playstation 5 and xbox series x
and s even across console platforms the
one-time migration option is available
to initiate now with different
instructions for gta 5 and gta online
for gta 5 players can upload their save
to the rockstar games social club for
gta online transfers it seems a little
simpler when loading up gta online for
the first time on playstation 5 or
series x and s players will be presented
with the opportunity to migrate their
characters cash progression stats
vehicles properties weapons clothing and
user created jobs hit the comment
section and let me know what year you
think gta 6 is coming out we'll see you
tomorrow wait no we won't tomorrow
saturday sorry forgot what day it was
for a second
see you next week